STRUGGLING SMALL BUSINESS THAT
IT WAS FOCUSED ON?
DALLAS MAVERICKS OWNER AND
ENTREPRENEUR MARK CUBAN IS HERE
ON THAT.
FIRST, MY THOUGHTS AT THE END OF
DAY 36, AMERICA IN SHUT DOWN.
WHEN WE STARTED TO TURN THE
CORNER ON THIS VIRUS, WE KNEW WE
WOULD SEE A CONSTANT EFFORT TO
BLUNT ANY GOOD NEWS.
MEDIA FIGURES, POLITICIANS, EVEN
SOME GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS SEEM
FAR TOO COMFORTABLE IN SHUTDOWN
MODE, IF YOU CAN BELIEVE IT.
NANCY PELOSI LIVES IN A
MULTIMILLION DOLLAR MANSION IN
THE PACIFIC HEIGHTS NEIGHBORHOOD
OF SAN FRANCISCO, IT’S VERY
NICE.
SHE SPENDS WEEKENDS AT HER
VINEYARD IN NAPA VALLEY, DO YOU
THINK SHE MINDS DOING HER PRESS
INTERVIEWS FROM HER GOURMET
KITCHEN?
>> WHAT HAVE YOU FOUND, WHAT ARE
YOU GOING TO SHARE WITH US?
>> CHOCOLATE.
CANDY.
>> WOW.
>> Laura: WHILE CHOOSING
BETWEEN THE LEMON PEACH GELATO
AND COCONUT SORBET, SHE LET
SMALL BUSINESSES DESPERATE FOR
RELIEF DANGLE.
SHE USED THEIR PAIN TO EXTRACT
CONFESSIONS THAT WERE TOTALLY
UNRELATED TO HELPING SMALL
BUSINESSES IN THAT PPP EXTENSION
BUILD THE PRESENT PLANS ON
SIGNING.
SHE’S NOT ALONE, MANY HAVE
PLAYED THE MOMENT FOR MAXIMUM
POLITICAL LEVERAGE AND SHAMELESS
SELF-PROMOTION.
THERE IS NO MINIMIZING THE
HORRIBLE HUMAN TRAGEDY OF THIS
VIRUS, IT’S A LOT OF PEOPLE AND
A LOT OF SUFFERING.
THERE IS GOOD NEWS OUT THERE.
THE INFECTION RATE IS DECLINING
IN MOST PLACES AROUND THE WORLD,
INCLUDING IN NEW YORK.
ALTHOUGH MORE THAN 44,000
AMERICANS HAVE LOST THEIR LIVES
TO COVID-19, WE HAVE 330 MILLION
MORE AMERICANS WHO STILL NEED TO
PROTECT AND RECLAIM THEIRS.
DOING THIS REQUIRES A FRANK
ASSESSMENT OF HOW WE GOT HERE.
WE WERE TOLD WE HAD TO SHUT
EVERYTHING DOWN IN ORDER TO SAVE
THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM.
TODAY, THE ONLY THING
THREATENING THE HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM THE SHUTDOWN ITSELF.
WE WERE TOLD WE HAD TO LOCK DOWN
BECAUSE WE DIDN’T HAVE ENOUGH
VENTILATORS.
NOW WE HAVE MORE THAN ENOUGH
NOW SOME GOVERNORS SAY THEY
CAN’T REOPEN BECAUSE THEY DON’T
HAVE ENOUGH TESTS.
HOW MANY?
SOME EXPERTS SAY WE NEED TO DO
20 MILLION TESTS A DAY.
THAT’S REALISTIC.
WE ARE DOING ROUGHLY 120,000
TESTS PER DAY RIGHT NOW, MORE
THAN ANY COUNTRY ON EARTH.
EVEN IF GOVERNORS SECURE THE
TESTS, THEY’RE GOING TO CLAIM
THEY CAN’T REOPEN UNTIL THEY
HAVE AN ARMY OF TRACERS AND THE
TRACKERS, HOW MANY DO THEY NEED?
ONE ESTIMATE SAYS THEY NEED
300,000.
HOW LONG WILL THAT TAKE THE SET
UP -- I CAN’T THINK OF IT, HOW
LONG WOULD IT TAKE TO TRAIN ALL
OF THOSE PEOPLE?
OUR STATE GOVERNORS PREPARED TO
PAY FOR IT ALL?
WHY SHOULD MONTANA HAVE TO PAY
THE BILL FOR DILL THE BLOVIATE
OR HIS MISTAKES?
EVEN IF WE HAVE ENOUGH TESTS AND
WORKERS DUE TO CONTACT TRACING,
WILL McABEE TOLD WE HAVE TO
STAY LOCKED DOWN UNTIL THERE’S A
VACCINE.
DR. FELT SHE HAD TAKEN TO CONCED
MAY NEVER HAVE A VACCINE, SARS
BURNED OUT BEFORE WE TESTED THE
ONE FROM MICE TO HUMANS.
WE DON’T HAVE A VACCINE FOR HIV
BUT WONDERFUL THERAPIES WERE
DEVELOPED TO SAVE LOTS OF LIVES.
THEY NEVER LIKED THE OLD NORMAL.
TRUMP WAS ELECTED DURING THE OLD
NORMAL DAYS.
BRETT KAVANAUGH WAS CONFIRMED TO
THE SUPREME COURT DURING THE OLD
NORMAL AND THE RUSSIA HOAX
COLLAPSED DURING THE NORMAL DAYS
DAYS.
NOW THOSE HAVE BEEN FRUSTRATED
AMERICA HASN’T EVOLVED FAST
ENOUGH TO AGGRESSIVE ENDS ARE
USING THIS CRISIS TO CHANGE
SOCIETY.
AS ANDREW CUOMO SAID, TO REMAKE
IT AND REIMAGINE IT.
RIGHT NOW, FRANK ASSESSMENT?
THEY ARE WINNING.
MILLIONS ARE OUT OF WORK AND
DEPENDENT ON A GOVERNMENT RESCUE
RESCUE.
DR. FAUCI IS FOCUSING ONLY ON
THE VIRUS, NOT ON THE BROADER
AMERICAN LIFE THAT MUST GO ON
BEFORE THE NATION ITSELF FLAT
LINES.
WHAT DOES THE PRESIDENT NEED TO
DO NOW?
NUMBER ONE, PUSH BACK AGAINST
ANY EFFORTS TO MOVE THE
GOALPOSTS.
WE’VE SAVED THE HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM IN NEW YORK, NO ONE IS
RUNNING SHORT OF VENTILATORS,
THOSE WERE THE REASONS THAT WE
SHUT DOWN AND THEY NO LONGER
APPLY.
NUMBER 2, CONTROL THE NARRATIVE
ON TESTING AND TRACKING, KEEP
EXPLAINING TO THE PRESS AND THE
GOVERNORS AND MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS AT THE U.S. GOVERNMENT
HAS MADE TESTING AND TRACKING
PROGRESS AND THEY ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO.
EMPHASIZE TWO KEY POINTS, OUR
EFFORTS HAVE BEEN WORLD-CLASS
AND CURRENT TESTING AND TRACKING
EFFORTS ARE SUFFICIENT TO ALLOW
SIGNIFICANT PORTIONS OF THE
COUNTRY TO REOPEN.
PLUS, THEY GOT $25 BILLION TODAY
FOR TESTING AND TRACKING IN THE
NEW DEAL.
NUMBER THREE, MAKE DEALS WITH
BLUE STATE GOVERNORS AND MAYORS,
THE PRESIDENT HAS DEMONSTRATED
TIME AND AGAIN, THIS IS MEANT A
GREAT ASPECT OF HIS LEADERSHIP
THAT HE’S WILLING TO WORK WITH
ANYONE AND EVERYONE TO GET
AMERICA BACK TO WORK, KEEP IT UP
UP.
SOME MIGHT ACT IN BAD FAITH, WE
KNOW THAT.
OTHERS JUST WANT THEIR PEOPLE TO
GET BACK TO WORK AND THEIR KIDS
BACK TO SCHOOL.
NUMBER FOUR, KEEP WORKING WITH
CONGRESS EVEN WHEN MEMBERS SEEM
UNREASONABLE AND MEAN-SPIRITED,
TAKE THE TEMPERATURE DOWN.
WE PASSED A SERIES OF THESE
SHORT-TERM MEASURES THAT ARE
DESIGNED TO GET THE MONEY IN
PEOPLE’S POCKETS AND GET THROUGH
THIS CRISIS.
NOW WE ARE GOING TO NEED
LEGISLATION THAT WILL HELP
RESTART AND REBUILD THE COUNTRY.
>> THE PRESIDENT SAID WE WOULD
LOOK FORWARD TO FACE FOUR WITH
THE INFRASTRUCTURE THE PRESIDENT
HAS BEEN TALKING ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE SINCE THE
CAMPAIGN, ROADS, BRIDGES,
BROADBAND, WE’VE TALKED ABOUT
INCENTIVES FOR RESTAURANTS,
SPORTS, ENTERTAINMENT BECAUSE
THESE BUSINESSES HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED, THE PRESIDENT HAS
TALKED MULTIPLE TIME ABOUT A
PAYROLL TAX CUTS.
>> Laura: 5, AMERICA FIRST NOW
MORE THAN EVER.
THE PRESIDENT WAS 100% CORRECT
TO USE HIS EXECUTIVE AUTHORITY
TO FREEZE IMMIGRATION DURING THE
CRISIS.
>> IT WOULD BE WRONG AND UNJUST
FOR AMERICANS TO BE LAID OFF BY
THE VIRUS AND REPLACED WITH NEW
IMMIGRANTS, LABOR FLOWING FROM
ABROAD.
WE WANT TO PROTECT OUR U.S.
WORKERS AS WE MOVE FORWARD, WE
WILL BECOME MORE AND MORE
PROTECTIVE OF THEM.
A SHORT BREAK FROM NEW
IMMIGRATION DEPENDING ON THE
TIME WE ARE TALKING ABOUT WILL
PROTECT THE SOLVENCY OF OUR
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM AND PROVIDE
RELIEF TO JOBLESS AMERICANS.
>> Laura: IT WOULD HAVE EVEN
BEEN MORE AMERICA FIRST AND
EFFECTIVE IF HE HAD EXTENDED
THIS PAUSE TO THE THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF TEMPORARY WORKERS
THAT COME IN EVERY YEAR.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT AND WILL BE
A VERY POPULAR START, ARE
AMERICANS GOING TO AGREE WITH
TRUMP?
NEARLY EIGHT IN TEN SUPPORT A
PAUSE -- THE USUAL SUSPECTS WERE
ENRAGED BY THIS MOVE, THEY
WANTED UNLIMITED IMMIGRATION,
EVEN DURING A PANDEMIC.
>> THAT’S NOT WHERE THE PROBLEM
IS COMING FROM AND IT AVOIDS HIM
HAVING TO DEAL WITH THE FACT
THAT WE WANT FOR ALMOST TWO
MONTHS OR MORE WITHOUT ACTION.
>> IT WILL ONLY BE UNDERSTOOD AS
A POLITICAL MATTER, NOT A PUBLIC
HEALTH MATTER, REDIRECTING SOME
BLAME TO FOREIGNERS WHO
PRESUMABLY HAVE SOMETHING TO DO
WITH IT.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS TRYING TO
FAN THE FLAMES OF XENOPHOBIA,
AMERICANS BROUGHT CORONAVIRUS
HERE.
IT WAS ALREADY HERE.
>> Laura: THAT’S LAUGHABLE,
THEY ACCUSED TRUMP OF XENOPHOBIA
WHEN HE SHUTDOWN TRAVEL FROM
CHINA, THEY ARE STILL DOING IT.
TRUMP HASN’T SMOKED THEM OUT
HERE BRILLIANTLY, THEY ARE
PERFECTLY HAPPY LOCKING DOWN THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WHILE THROWING
THE DOORS OPEN TO THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE FROM EVERY COUNTRY ON
EARTH.
SHAME A MILLENNIAL IN THE
GROCERY STORE FOR NOT WEARING A
MASK BUT WELCOME ASYMPTOMATIC
SPREADERS, IT’S ON US, THE
AMERICAN TAXPAYER.
THAT’S HOW RADICAL THESE PEOPLE
ARE ON THE ISSUE OF IMMIGRATION,
THEY WON’T EVEN LET US GO TO
CHURCH IF WE ARE SITTING 6 FEET
APART BUT THEY WANT IMMIGRATION
FLOWING LIKE THERE WAS NEVER A
CRISIS.
UNTIL THE LOCKDOWN FOLKS ARE
WILLING TO SUPPORT EFFORTS TO
REOPEN THE ECONOMY, THERE IS NO
POSITION TO INSIST IMMIGRATION
SHOULD CONTINUE AS NORMAL,
THAT’S ABSURD.
THE PRESIDENT IS SHOWING US HOW
AMERICA FIRST GOES FROM BEING A
CAMPAIGN THEME TO A WAY OF LIFE.